i was born to two amazing professors
who are not religious in fact my
father's regular response the question
about why we did not go to church on
sundays was when others go to pray
i go to play tennis in case you're
wondering
faith found me and my siblings when
university students came to our house
to invite us to sunday school i was
drawn
by their sense of personal conviction
and their life of service
and opted for baptism into the christian
faith
as my tenth birthday present my faith
has shaped my work as a social
entrepreneur
attempting to address africa's most
pressing challenges over the last 17
years
and my work training youth as leaders
and promoting ethics across africa
29 years later as a sunday school
teacher myself
my faith was challenged by a young
nine-year-old
who asked a series of questions
he asked miss indiri
does god hate africans
to wish i quickly retorted of course not
god loves all his children equally
then he asks so why do so many young
african children die
i stumbled and mumbled as i responded
there are many reasons why young african
children die
most of them are man-made and we cannot
blame god
so he asked why does it why does he let
it happen he could stop it
and i said yes he could
yes he could but he sent us here as
change agents
light of the world salt of the earth and
we are failing
africa has had a mixed affair with
organized religion
with both positive and negative
consequences
the christian missionaries educated most
about political elites
like sanguan and kruma built many of our
first hospitals
and schools similarly
islam has introduced commerce
and mathematics across the continent
today we have over a billion africans
who profess a strong faith
what is the net effects of this on our
continents
a recent economist article said that the
face
of the future of the world's most
popular religion
is african now both
islam and christianity underscored the
importance of
social impacts as critical tenants of
our faith
mohammed is noted for stating
that he is not a believer who goes to
bed
on a full stomach when his neighbor to
his side is hungry
and all through the new testament jesus
christ talks about loving your neighbors
as yourselves
giving to the poor caring for the sick
and james 2 says that faith without
works is dead
so i strongly believe that faith-based
organizations have a critical role
to play in driving social impacts in
africa
but for this to occur we need three
critical changes
the first is that we need to change our
mindsets
both as people of faith and on those who
are not religious
their perceptions of those of us who are
people of faith
now for people of faith and those of us
who are religious
we often say if god wills i'll do this
inshallah i'll do that
by god's grace i'll do this now there
are many things
i believe that we can control some we
cannot
i believe that god is all-powerful but
he's not a micro-manager
he has sent us here as his change agents
and we must stop making excuses and
using him
that means that if you're a teacher go
to school and give your students the
best
if you're a public sector official
release the funds meant for that school
or public health care center
instead of stealing it for your personal
purposes
by claiming that we have no power over
our past
present and future we give too much
authority to the wicked
who steal funds and beg god for
forgiveness
now for those of you who are not
religious you also have to change your
mindsets about us
there are many of us who are
hard-working ethical
and intellectual it might surprise you
now the second step is that we have to
utilize
our resources and assets for social
impacts
in england a thousand nine hundred
churches have been
shut down since 1969
due to shrinking congregations while in
africa
every single day a church or mosque is
being built
in some communities you might not find a
public health center
a post office or even a school but
you'll find a church or mosque
some of these churches and mosques are
world class
with excellent audio visual systems
wonderful meeting spaces
and they organize events that rival
international concerts
the sad reality is that many of them are
empty during the week
i live in the lackey area of lagos
and in my community there are at least
50 really nice churches
but there's no adult literacy center no
homeless
shelter and very few public schools and
hospitals
many of these spaces could be utilized
for social change imagine
if every single church in leckie opened
its doors to the homeless at night
gave them a sleeping bag a warm meal and
a voucher
in the morning to learn a vocational
course
offered by the unemployed youth who
attend their church
that would demonstrate what we preach
and what we speak about as people of
faith
and what led me to christianity in the
first place
similarly we have to utilize
our resources for social change
the 2016 why give survey conducted in
kenya reveals that close to 60 percent
of adults
give to faith-based organizations even
more than they give the extended
families
this is not unique to kenya it's quite
prevalent across africa
many of our faith-based organizations
have tremendous amounts of wealth
can be can be utilized for social change
we have to check the sources of uses of
this funds
and curb the excesses by our faith-based
organizations
now this will require courage on the
part of members
who will have to put their imbalance and
priests on straight salaries
require audited financial statements
that will be published
and even rejects contributions from
unethical sources
but it's possible we're already seeing
positive examples in south africa and
kenya
and the organizations such as the africa
council for accountability and
accreditation
that's checking faith-based
organizations and ensuring that they
comply with biblical standards of
stewardship
now the third step is that we have to
partner with all stakeholders
and this is especially relevant for the
non-religious in the audience
recognizing the power and potential of
faith-based organizations
leveraging the assets their scale the
public trust and credibility they have
they are lower operating costs they
access the grassroots and their presence
abroad
politicians recognize this and campaign
seasons
are always filled with stops and picture
opportunities with leading faith leaders
sadly once elected many of these faith
based organizations i ignored
and in fact a world bank survey revealed
that 30 to 70 percent
of assets owned by medical organizations
in africa actually owned by faith-based
organizations
but that there's very little
collaboration between the faith
community
and public health care systems one
positive example
is from ghana where the ghana catholic
health service partnered with a range of
stakeholders
and was able to realize a 31
reduction in mortality
i believe there's so much potential that
can be realized
when we walk across the divide of faith
and hand in hand tries to solve many of
our problems
similarly faith-based organizations can
support the transfer of critical skills
and knowledge
many of you in the ngo community or in
the private sectors
realize how difficult it is to even
attract 150 to 200 people to your
conferences
sometimes offering stipends
reimbursements of transportation costs
meanwhile faith-based organizations draw
thousands
and millions every sunday or friday
with the promise of a good sermon
the truth is we cannot address issues
around family planning without
faith-based organizations in africa
issues such as democratic rights and
voter registration ensuring that every
member of a congregation
has a voter's registration card
understands their democratic rights
and can exercise that
i really think it's critical that we
consider partnering with faith-based
organizations to deliver social impacts
it's also important to note that africa
faith-based organizations have a strong
presence globally
there are over 2 000 african nuns and
priests in leadership positions in
europe
with more influence than some of our
diplomatic envoys
operating at a fraction of the cost they
can serve as influencers
and supporters similarly some african
churches have a presence
in countries across the globe and the
redeemed christian church of god
has a presence in 196 countries
servants are bridged to the diaspora and
providing support
if our public sector organizations could
partner with these institutions
we could unlock the potential of our
diaspora populations
i know some of you are still struggling
with this topic
but i would challenge you to think about
it a wise man once said
faith is a risk but it's a risk that i
cannot afford not to take
i would suggest that partnerships with
faith-based organization is a risk
but one that all stakeholders that are
committed to social impacts
in africa cannot afford not to take
i often reflect on my conversation with
that young boy
and i believe i should have ended it a
little differently
first i should have commended him for
asking tough questions
africa needs more young people who
challenge a status quo
even in the faith communities secondly
i should have given him a little more
hope not hope in the afterlife
but hope in africa today
because the faithful are powerful not
just because of their beliefs
but because of their assets their
resources the army of volunteers
and because working together across the
divide
we can live as positive examples
for what our children my children your
children deserves to see
an africa that demonstrates that god
loves africans
and that we are just as capable as any
other world region
in solving our problems in peace
and love i love this quote
that says hope
is the ability to hear the melody of the
future
faith is the willingness and the courage
to dance to it today
i hope that we as people of faith
can truly live up to the promise of
social impact
that we have been called to do as change
agents in society
and i believe that working with you all
stakeholders
we can truly solve africa's most
pressing challenges
i have that hope and
i have the faith and i've started to
dance won't you join me
thank you